. We have a voicemail number.
The number is two one nine two David P..
I kind of like this question because it's
a straightforward question about the November
election.
Yeah.
David, this is Michael from Roseville, Indiana.
And I just want to know how likely is it that
Trump will win the 2020 election?
Yeah, I mean, listen.
OK, I love it's a simple question.
There is no answer to that.
So so when I talk about polling and a lot
of the polling looks good for Joe Biden right
now, doesn't tell us what's going to happen
in November.
Ultimately, November is going to be a referendum
on Trump, specifically with regard to the
state of the economy in the aftermath of corona
virus.
And it may not actually be the aftermath.
Right.
We may be in a continued very long first wave.
We may be in a second wave in November.
I don't know.
But ultimately, we don't know.
Trump very well could get himself reelected
if the perception is corona virus is gone,
at least for now, in late October, early November.
If Trump can propagandize the Q3 GDP numbers,
as I suggested earlier today, that he will
if Trump can say, well, look at this start
of a recovery, beautiful GDP numbers in Q3,
ignoring the disaster that was Q2, he can
get himself reelected for sure.
And if it's close, it's much better for Donald
Trump to get pushed over the edge in just
a couple of states the way he was in 2016
with Hillary Clinton.
So my message is look at the polls from an
educational perspective and make sure that
no matter what the polls say, no matter what
state you live in.
You recognize that you must vote.
We all must vote or we are going to be dealing
with another four years of this insanity.
I hope you'll join me on the bonus show today.
We will talk about what's going on with the
in-person Republican National Convention.
We will talk about insulin and the president's
recent focus on it.
We will talk about Republicans suing to stop
the move to allow remote votes in the House
of Representatives, something that would be
great to put in place.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show get instant access by becoming a member
on my Web site or by becoming a patron at
patrie on dot com slash David Pakman show.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.